hey this is presh chillwalker
let's say you have all of these
fractions and you need to convert them
into their decimal representation
how do you do it
it's going to be a challenging task but
there's a trick that will make it much
easier
so let's start out with something easy
let's calculate the decimal
representation for one over three
you probably learned this in school and
remember that it's equal to 0.3
repeating
but how do schools teach it for the very
first time how do you figure out this
decimal representation
so this is the way I learned it and I
think many people still learn it this
way
you start out with the numerator the
number one
then you draw this line
and you want to divide it by three so we
put three on this side
now how many times does 3 go into one
three is larger than one so it goes into
one zero times
so from there we need to add a decimal
point which we will put also in the
answer
we then put a zero
so we now ask how many times does 3 go
into ten
three times three is equal to nine so we
put a 3 here 3 times 3 is 9. we subtract
the nine ten minus nine is equal to one
we now need to add a zero which we carry
down so now we have ten once again 3
goes into ten three times three times
three is nine
subtracting nine from ten we get one and
we can see the pattern is going to
continue each time we're going to get 3
so we have point three three repeating
and that's how 1 over 3 is equal to 0.3
repeating
but is there an easier way to do this
so here's a trick I think that is pretty
cool we all know that one is equal to
0.9 repeating so if we divide both sides
by three we get 1 over 3 is equal to 0.9
repeating divided by three
so let's do this calculation
point nine divided by 3 is equal to 0.3
we then shift 1 over then 9 divided by 3
is equal to three we shift one over nine
divided by three is equal to 3 and we
see that this pattern is going to go on
forever so 1 divided by 3 is equal to
0.3 repeating
let's see how this trick can help to
solve other problems let's do 1 over 11.
Now 1 is equal to 0.9 repeating
and we remember that 11 times 9 or 11
times 09 is equal to 99. so we can
represent 0.9 repeating as 0.99
repeating then 99 divided by 11 is equal
to 09
so this will be equal to 0.09 repeating
and that's it 1 over 11 is equal to 0.09
repeating
let's solve another problem what is 5
over 11
well 5 over 11 is equal to 5 times 1
over 11. we just figured out that 1 over
11 is equal to 0.09 repeating
now 5 times 0.09 will be equal to 0.45
so we get that 5 over 11 is equal to
0.45 repeating amazing
now let's solve 1 divided by 33 1 is
equal to 0.9 repeating point nine
repeating is equal to 0.99 repeating
then 33 times O3 is equal to 99 so this
is equal to 0.03 repeating
next problem
what is 1 divided by 101
we'll immediately think about our
strategy
101 times 99 is equal to
9999 so we will represent 1 by
0.99999 repeating
we can then do the division that this is
equal to
.0099 repeating notice we need four
digits because we have
9999 is four digits so one divided by
101 is equal to
.0099 repeating
next question
what is 1 divided by 271
we again use a strategy
271 times 369 is equal to 99 999.
so we will have a numerator with five
decimal places that are repeating
we need to include two leading zeros
here so this is equal to point zero zero
three six nine repeating these five
digits repeat forever
now what if you had to solve one over
six you can't directly get an easy
multiplication like we've been doing but
this strategy might still help one is
equal to 0.9 repeating so let's set up
our problem the old-fashioned way but
imagine here we have an infinite number
of Nines in the decimal representation
so when we do the long division the old
way well 6 goes into zero zero times now
how many times does six go into 9 it
goes into it one time so we have point
one we have nine minus six is equal to
three
now we carry down a nine
so how many times does six go into 39
that would be six times and then six
times six is equal to 36 we do this
subtraction and we get a three we carry
down the nine and we'll get 39 again so
we're going to see the next digit is
going to be six and the same pattern
will repeat forever so we have that one
divided by six is equal to 0.166
repeating or it's equal to 0.16
repeating
now let's say we need to solve one over
seven
of course everyone knows that 7 times 14
28 57 is equal to nine nine nine nine
nine nine
so now we have a decimal representation
that will be six digits that are
repeating
so 1 over 7 will be equal to 14 28.57
and all six of these digits repeat
final example what is 1 over 17
well if you work it out 17 times this
number is equal to a number that has
only nines if you count the number of
digits carefully you'll see we'll need a
leading zero here and one over Seventeen
is equal to the following decimal
representation now let me end the video
with a little bit of justification for
why 0.9 repeating is equal to one
because no math video is complete
without some rigorous formal notation
that very few people understand and find
interesting so here we go 0.9 repeating
is defined as the limit as n goes to
Infinity of a decimal which is 0.99 we
have n different spaces of nine this is
the definition
now we can also write it in the
following way we have a sum of 9 over 10
plus 9 over 100 plus so on to 9 over 10
to the power of n we take the limit as n
goes to Infinity of this geometric sum
now you'll notice this sum is 1 over 10
to the N less than one so this is equal
to the Limit as n goes to Infinity of 1
minus 1 over 10 to the power of n
we can write this as 1 minus the limit
as n goes to Infinity of 1 over 10 to
the power of n this limit will go to
zero so this is equal to one minus 0 and
this is equal to one
therefore 0.9 repeating is equal to one
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]